it was a proper Easter family gathering
as the Queen's children and
grandchildren waited outside since
George's Chapel to welcome her on her
birthday
turning 93 Britain's longest-reigning
monarch was on remarkable form in
Windsor people lined the streets to
catch a glimpse of the Royals
among them was Sonya who shares her
birthday with her majesty and was in the
congregation she was born in 1926 Knives
born in 1962 and they played happy
birthday on the organ 30 years after
most of us would be considering
retirement her life is still one of
constant service duty and being on
public display younger members of the
family have stepped up their official
duties and now speculation about a new
role for Sussex as' is the latest signal
there could be more change on the way
[Music]
after their successful overseas tours
The Sunday Times has reported that
Palace officials want to capitalize on
their huge international appeal and that
could mean the couple living and working
abroad Africa could be an option a place
where Harry already has connections
interestingly in a statement the palace
have not denied the reports but said
that any future plans for the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex are speculative at the
moment they also go on to say that no
decision has been made about future
roles for Harry and Megan simply adding
that Prince Harry will continue with his
role as a Youth Ambassador for the
Commonwealth
becoming a father is no doubt one roll
at the front of Harry's mind at the
moment with Megan at home do to give
birth any day but it's not surprising
that work could be going on behind the
scenes to make the most of this popular
couple the chance of allowing the queen
who is getting much older now to send
that these two young enthusiastic
ambassadors to try and bring together
all the very best benefits of the
Commonwealth is precisely why the royal
family works well for the Queen when she
can find new and exciting tasks for
those of a new generation it may be her
grandchildren who often grab the
headlines they realized they are the
supporting cast to a record-breaking
monic
and not just on her birthday Rhiannon
Mills Sky News in winter